texas the governor there has turned to
mexico to settle part of a border fight
with the biden administration important
border crossings had been backed up for
days after governor greg abbott ordered
tighter inspection of trucks entering
the u.s
now he's letting most of those trucks
through but he's also sending buses full
of migrants to washington d.c to make a
point abbott is angry with a federal
plan to end coveted restrictions that
had prevented many people from crossing
the southern border edoki is at the
white house for us ed good morning to
you the wall street journal editorial
board did not like this move
apparently they didn't that's right but
in this case the governor is ending this
controversial border policy in at least
some spots because he's got deals now
with two mexican governors who plan to
step up screenings on the southern side
of the border meanwhile here in
washington abbott's mounting a more
symbolic criticism of the biden
administration's immigration policy
the bridge between chihuahua and texas
will return to normal
immediately under mounting pressure to
reverse a border security policy that
shut down some of the country's busiest
trade bridges texas governor greg abbott
thursday announced another agreement
this time with the mexican state of
chihuahua
to return to business as usual these
actions are impacting people's jobs and
the livelihoods of hard-working families
in texas and across the country the
governor's been insisting on new
inspection rules for commercial trucks
entering from mexico leading to backups
lasting several hours even days
one of the biggest effects is on the
delivery of fresh produce we could see
consumers paying double the price for
avocados double the price for tomatoes
double the price for strawberries for
really no good reason we need the trucks
to start moving abbott says he's
responding to the cdc's decision to end
title 42. the trump era policy allows
border agents to expel migrants for
public health reasons and ends in late
may
republicans and a growing number of
democrats say the biden administration
needs a better plan to manage an
expected surge of migrants texas is
tired of being the unloading dock for
illegal immigrants crossing the border
the new unloading dock is going to be
washington d.c and in a symbolic
criticism of the biden administration
abbott has sent at least two busloads of
immigrants already processed by customs
and border protection to washington it's
nice the state of texas is helping them
get to their final destination as they
await in their their outcome of their
immigration proceedings
abbott says those enhanced inspections
will continue elsewhere along the 1200
mile span between texas and mexico until
similar agreements are reached with
other mexican governors and of course
all of this is a reminder that whether
it's in texas florida arizona georgia
new hampshire wisconsin you name it
places holding competitive gubernatorial
and congressional elections later this
year immigration remains and will be an
urgent issue of concern likely to divide
or gin up the base ahead of november's
elections
tony that is that is definitely true ed
thank you very much